françois legault chef de la coalition
avenir québec bonsoir à vous bonsoir de
ce roi deux jours de caucus à bromont on
va parler dans un instant de ce que vous
proposez pour l'économie en 37 baisses
d'impôt de 500 dollars par québécois
mais avant d'une petite question
d'actualité d'abord on apprend que le
remaniement finalement aura lieu jeudi
matin et vous est ce qu'il ya des mines
est ce que vous vous dites faut vraiment
qu'il ne soit plus ministre jeudi après
midi
bah écoutez d'abord la priorité je pense
actuellement avec ce qu'on a vu sur les
marchés boursiers depuis quelques
semaines c'est vraiment d'économie sjtu
est inquiet la situation économique au
québec
mais évidemment on peut se poser des
questions sur le sud est où mais le
premier responsable c'est le poids ni
médiation on a besoin d'un capitaine qui
var une obsession d'attirer à chaque
semaine des investissements des
entreprises au québec sa responsabilité
d'abord de monsieur couillard et vous ne
voyez pas ce actuellement je vois pas ça
du tout on voit des investissements des
entreprises qui sont en baisse
une très faible croissance économique là
encore cette semaine
desjardins a révisé à la baisse sa
croissance économique prévue au québec
pour cette année à peu près à la moitié
de ce qui est prévu en ontario et aux
états unis
donc il faut faire beaucoup mieux en
économie et faut arrêter de piger d'un
poches des citoyens
actuellement ils sont étouffés puis un
problème de consommation des ménages
dans l'économie québécoise mais parlons
ça te tuer de cette offre que vous
faites en fait d'une idée que vous
lancez 500 $ à chaque québécois tout de
suite là qu'on irait puiser dans le
fonds des générations à ce que c'était
parfait pour rembourser la dette le
fonds des générations
bon d'abord ce qui est important de
préciser c'est que pour l'année qui
vient pour l'année 2016 2017 on prévoit
un surplus budgétaire de 2,2 milliards
de dollars qui serait versée au fonds
des générations
actuellement il est à peu près aucun
état dans le monde compte tenu de la
situation économique difficile qui fait
des surplus donc c'est pas normal qu'on
soit en surplus qu'on ne vienne pas
stimuler l'économie et on pense
qu'actuellement là où ça fait le plus
mal au québec quand on décortique un
petit peu le pib c'est vraiment la
consommation des ménages ces 60
sein de l'économie et nous on pense que
on n'arrivera pas à relancer l'économie
si on donne pas un peu d'oxygène aux
gens là on parle de tous ceux qui ont
des revenus en boîte 150 mille dollars
1,5 équivalente 500 dollars oui
absolument
pour qu'un consomme pour refaire
repartir la machine
dites vous est-ce que par ailleurs c'est
vous dites les états n'ont pas de
surplus la plupart compte tenu de la
situation difficile lorsque par ailleurs
on n'a pas trop couper dans des
programmes on a vu des plus vulnérables
depuis deux semaines ça fait là film
dirais plutôt qu'on aime mal coupées
rappelez-vous durant la campagne
électorale en 2014 la cave est programme
nos très détaillé sur commente l
équilibre budgétaire en réduisant les
dépenses
on y allait surtout dans les dépenses de
bureaucratie de vieux 220 mille employés
qui ne donne pas de service on réduisait
ce nombre de 20 milles lorsqu'on a vu
depuis la nuit de monsieur kouyaté des
coûts peut surtout de service ça soit
dans les cpe que ce soit dans les écoles
même pour les enfants qui ont des
difficultés d'apprentissage tout ça soit
en toxicomanie on coupe dans les
services ça c'est pas normal donc
effectivement on est mal fait le travail
du côté des dépenses
mais il faut aussi donner de l'oxygène
aux gens parce que depuis que monsieur
couillard est en poste depuis un an et
demi on augmentait en moyenne 2500
dollars les taxes et les tarifs des
québécois donc les québécois en 1500 $
de moins dans leur poche avec la
proposition qu'on fait aujourd'hui on
vient leur donner pour une famille avec
deux adultes là mais le dollar pour
passer absolument nécessaire pour
relancer l'économie du québec
très bien par ailleurs votre parti et
pour le pipeline énergie s on en parle
depuis deux jours sans arrêt
expliquez-nous pourquoi qu'est ce qui
fait que vous vous dites ce projet là
est bon pour l'économie du québec
justement
bon d'abord ce qu'on a dit depuis le
début à la cac c'est que on n'est pas
dogmatique comme le parti québécois on
est ouvert aux projets mais à deux
conditions
d'abord il faut minimiser les risques
environnementaux entre autres les
risques de déversements de pétrole et 2
faut surtout que le gouvernement du
québec demandent des redevances
importantes pour la partie du pétrole
qui sont exportés je peux comprendre que
ça soit le cas mais sur le bois tu sais
effectivement pas le corps puis monsieur
arcand puis monsieur couillard le dise
du bout des lèvres mais on sait pas
combien puis on sait même pas si on
demandé mais si l'alberta réalise des
dizaines de milliards de dollars de
revenus en exportant du pétrole en
passant sur le territoire du québec
c'est pas normal que le québec prennent
tous les risques qu'ils reçoivent
habillé en échange il faut demander des
milliards de dollars de redevances donc
une espèce de taxes à l'exportation
ce pétrole pas ce moment alors ça
pourrait devenir un projet intéressant
parce que moi ce que je souhaite à terme
ne sait pas que le québec continue de
recevoir de la péréquation qui viennent
l'alberta c'est qu'on soit des revenus
qu'on soit aussi riche que l'alberta
qu'on arrête de recevoir des revenus de
péréquation donc il faut demander des
redevances puis il faut être très
exigeant puis je vois pas ça du côté de
monsieur couillard si on n'a pas de
redevances dans les négociations vous
dites ça vous placez s'y rendre une
avance là actuellement là il ya beaucoup
trop de risques pour les faibles
retombées pour le québec donc le projet
comme il est bâti actuellement n'est pas
intéressant financièrement pour le
québec
très bien dernier point on attend vous
entendu certains vous députés aussi dire
aujourd'hui il ya des députés du parti
québécois qui nous parle dans le rail
qui disent on est peut-être intéressés
est ce que c'est vrai oui oui c'est vrai
mais en même temps on peut pas et plus
que ça de lui à partir du moment où on
dit des discussions avec certains
députés
vous allez comprendre le mettez vous à
leur place là qu'on peut pas en dire
plus et effectivement ça se met à
réaliser que des gens qui viennent à la
cac dont la non sport quand ça se refait
ma actuellement ça reste des discussions
entre différentes personnes mais de
toute façon il semble y avoir un malaise
du côté du parti québécois il n'y a pas
mieux vaut paraît clair il n'y a pas de
discussions sérieuses
actuellement avec un deux trois députés
du pq c'était sérieux j'en parle de riez
pas j'imagine bien écouter on m'a posé
la question mais je l'a peut-être la
fâcheuse habitude de dire la vérité
quand on pose la question on m'a demandé
est ce que vous êtes au courant qu'il ya
des députés du pq qui sont en réflexion
pour quitter le pays qu je dis oui je
t'oublie je dis oui puisqu'il faudra
vous non il parle à des personnes qui
sont près de moi très bien sur l'agout
merci d'avoir été là
merci je crois que vous avez passé deux
jours en caucus présessionnel à bromont
merci à la prochaine merci a bientot au
revoir